- I'm definitely going to need
my--my blade sharpened.
- [indistinct].
- 'Cause I used it right up
until T-minus.
I had some glitches in the
preparation
of my original blade,
and then, like, at the last
minute,
I had to have someone step in,
make me a blade
really in less than a week.
- Wow.
- And get it from
Denver, Colorado, to New York.
He really worked tirelessly...
- I bet.
- To get that to me.
- Yeah.
- He worked so hard.
- My blade, I had to have mine
custom-made.
I hadn't touch mine till I got
here.
I had seen pictures of it,
but I hadn't physically put
hands on it...
- Wow.
- Until I got here.
- So are you nervous about
taking something
you've never swung out there?
- Are you?
- Yeah, a little, a little.
I have trust in the maker.
- That's important.
Did you hear it's designed
after a "Hellboy" weapon
from the movie "Hellboy"?
- No.
- That's his.
- Yeah.
- His, it's designed after
the "Hellboy" number two.
- Wow.
- It's--
I'm a big comic book geek.
- I think that's cool.
- So...
- I loved "Hellboy."
- For me being able to kind of
ring that in
and still use my fundamentals,
like,
my slashings,
the slashing attack from the
[indistinct]
are gonna be basically the same
with this blade,
and that's why I chose the
specific blade
and length and grip and
everything else,
because I'm, like,
I don't want to change up from
what I normally do...
- Right.
- What I'm normally
dealing with.
- Right.
You're gonna have to be
instinctual now.
Now it's time for instinct.
- Yeah, I mean--
- This is, like, not time for
testing or anything.
You just--we're all gonna be
who we are now.
- Going into this, my thing is
just focus on my technique.
- Yes.
- That's it.
- Focus on what brought you to
the game.
- That's right.
- Because if you go out there
and let your mind wander...
- Yeah, no, no, no.
- It's here. It's gone.
It's gone.
Do what--do what--let your body
do it; let your body go.